da hatte schon eingeblendet da ist
angela merkel die alte bundeskanzlerin
geschäftsführende demnächst und olaf
scholz der vize bundeskanzler der
vielleicht demnächst neue bundeskanzler
ist und auftritt frank walter steinmeier
anhören der mann nimmt
verehrte frau bundeskanzlerin
verehrte damen und herren
bundesministerin bundesministerin die
entlassung der bundesregierung aus dem
amt ist ein formeller akt deshalb hören
einige von ihnen heute einen satz den
sie vor vier jahren fast wortgleich
schon einmal gehört haben
mit der konstituierung des 29 deutschen
bundestages
endet nach artikel 69 absatz 2 des
grundgesetzes
ihr amt
doch viel mehr als diese nüchterne
formel
haben beide anlässe kaum gemeint viel
sehr viel hat sich in den vergangenen
vier jahren ereignet zu sagen die
vergangenen legislatur sei
herausfordernd gewesen
trifft die aufgaben die es zu bewältigen
galt
nicht einmal annähernd die pandemie hat
die welt aus den angeln gehoben
sie hat ihnen sehr dem ganzen land
enormes abverlangt als
bundeskanzlerin als ministerinnen und
minister dieser regierung
haben sie verantwortung getragen für
unser land mit aller kraft und
ernsthaftigkeit die diese situation
ihnen abforderte sie haben sich diese
aufgabe gemeinsam gestellt zum vierten
mal in der geschichte der bundesrepublik
in einer so genannten großen koalition
große aufgaben verlangen große allianzen
die demokratie aber erfordert ebenso den
respekt vor demokratische opposition
und den stetigen ausgleich von
interessen
die balance zu halten das ist die
antriebsfeder wenn man so will die
unruhe im uhrwerk der demokratie
es ist der wichtigste und zugleich
schwierigste teil des regierungshandelns
und dass er gelingt es selbst den
weniger herausfordernden weniger
aufgeregten zeiten
keine selbstverständlichkeit in diesen
zeiten war der ausgleich besonders
manchmal beinahe zum zerreißen schwer
denn wir erinnern uns von anfang an
standen diese jahre unter dem eindruck
wachsender
polarisierung in der gesellschaft samt
verrohung der sprache im netz die auf
den straßen diese jahre standen auch im
zeichen internationaler spannung den
schwierigen prozess des breaks sitz in
europa und jedenfalls in den ersten
jahren ihrer amtszeit einer
amerikanischen regierung deren
internationale ordnung und
transatlantische partnerschaft
wenig bis nichts belegen würden
und wir erinnern uns auch daran schon
der beginn dieser koalition da alles
andere als einfach und gerade am anfang
war sie nach schwierigen monaten der
regierungsbildung fliehkräften und auch
harscher kritik ausgesetzt aber am ende
galt ein gemeinsames prinzip sie wollten
die verantwortung die sie sich
demokratisch beworben hatten
wahrnehmen das haben sie getan und dafür
gebühren ihnen
respekt und dank
unser land hat es hat in den vergangenen
monaten erleben können
dass die demokratie in unserem land
an prüfungen gewachsen ist deshalb weil
ihre vertreter
verantwortungsvoll unter demokraten
handelten die demokratischen kräfte in
regierung und parlament haben sorge
dafür getragen dass
polarisierung und provokationen sich
nicht durchsetzen konnten
diese gemeinsame anstrengung war
erfolgreich und das ist ein erfolg nicht
nur für sie sondern für die demokratie
insgesamt
diese ist eine legislaturperiode
die gewiss auch in den erinnerungen
künftiger generationen von der pandemie
geprägt und gezeichnet sein wird aber
zum politischen gelingen dieser
legislatur hat auch vieles andere
beigetragen nicht zuletzt die umsetzung
ihrer politischen vorhaben
jenseits von krisenbekämpfung rund 600
gesetze sind in ihrer regierungszeit
verabschiedet worden und damit viele
konkrete verbesserungen in der
gesellschaft erreicht wurden für
pflegende angehörige zum beispiel für
familien und alleinerziehende für den
schutz von mieterinnen und mietern oder
parität in der gesetzlichen
krankenversicherung den ausbau der
kinderbetreuung und die zuwanderung von
fachkräften die wir dringend brauchten
und gerade mit blick auf die demokratie
ist mehr eines wichtig sie haben den
spaltungstendenzen in der gesellschaft
der verrohung und dem hass nicht nur
guten willen entgegengesetzt sondern
konkrete politik ich denke an die
stärkung der demokratie förderung des
kinderschutzes an die verschärfung des
waffengesetzes
höhere entschädigungen für opfer von
gewalttaten und ich denke an die
gesetzespakete gegen hass und hetze im
internet
das mit dem corona wiederaufbau von und
der
oftmals kritisierten europäischen
beschaffung von impfstoffen der
zusammenhalt nicht nur auf nationaler
sondern auch auf europäischer ebene
erhalten blieb würde ich heute besonders
hervorheben für europa
war und ist die bekämpfung der pandemie
und ihrer konsequenzen
nicht nur eine frage der glaubwürdigkeit
sondern der existenz und ich glaube ohne
ihre entscheidungen
hätte europa zerbrechen können dafür bin
ich dankbar auch wenn wir alle wissen
der innere zusammenhalt europas bleibt
fragil
und der abbau von spannungen der
interessensausgleich in europa bleibt
zentrale aufgabe auch jeder neuen
bundesregierung
meine damen und herren was die
heutige formelle entlassung der
bundesregierung mehr als alles andere
von vorangegangenen abhebt ist das ende
einer kanzlerschaft die man zu den
großen in der geschichte dieser republik
zählen kann für sie verehrte frau
bundeskanzlerin
enten 16 jahre regierungszeit auch wenn
das wie wir wissen keine beispiellos
lange amtszeit war so waren diese jahre
doch
beispielgebend und wenn wir glaubwürdig
berichtet wurde heute ein elfjähriges
kind fragt
ob denn auch ein mann kanzlerin werden
könne
dann zeugt das von einem neuen
selbstverständlichkeit
die es vor der ersten frau im kanzleramt
nicht gab und natürlich auch von den
großen respekt den sie sich in unserem
land und in der ganzen welt erworben
haben
meine damen und herren wir erleben will
was diesen respekt begründete sollte
sich ein interview ansehen dass günter
gaus 1991 lange vor ihrer ersten
amtszeit als kanzlerin mit ihnen geführt
hat
es ließ mich als ich es wieder sahen
ihre sehr persönliche rede zum die
serien tag der deutschen einheit denken
anlass des interviews war ihre
nominierung zur stellvertretenden
parteivorsitzenden cdu als nachfolgerin
lothar de maizière ist
günter gaus war offenkundig
irritiert von der rasanz dieses
politischen aufstiegs einer noch nahezu
unbekannten an die parteispitze der
union er fragte sie ob
es ihnen nicht auch ein wenig zu schnell
dinge ob sie nicht fürchten nicht
zitiere mehr objekt als subjekt der
eigenen geschichte zu sein und zu werden
ach wissen sie
meine inneren mechanismen sind ganz
intakt
antworteten sie mit feinem leicht
verschmitzten lächeln auf diese fast ein
wenig unwirsch gestellte frage
wir sehen in diesem interview eine junge
politikerin die sehr konzentriert und
überzeugend
ein ostdeutsches selbstbewusstsein
vertritt
da das mit westdeutscher
selbstgewissheit eben nicht zu
verwechseln ist eine ostdeutsche die
weiß dass ihre lebensgeschichte sie zur
eigenen erfahrungen und erkenntnissen
geführter die nach dem ende der ddr
nicht einfach ein entwerteter fahrschein
in den westen war und die überzeugt
davon ist dass diese erfahrung in der
parteiführung der cdu wie in der
bundesdeutschen politik insgesamt
ihren platz finden müsse wenn die
einheit gelingen sollte und
frau bundeskanzlerin sie sollten recht
behalten
man kann aus diesem 30 jahre alten
gespräch viel lernen wer es noch einmal
sieht sieht schon dort eine frau die
prägend sein sollte prägend für unser
wieder vereintes land
und für das bild unseres landes in der
welt prägen für eine ganze generation
junger frauen und männer denen sie eine
neue
ganz eigene form der führung vorgelegt
haben frau bundeskanzlerin wir haben
ihnen
für 16 jahre zu danken in denen sie
unser land durch eine zeit geführt haben
die nicht eben arm an krisen und
verwerfungen war es waren jahre großer
krisen der finanz und wirtschaftskrise
zu beginn ihrer regierungszeit
der euro-krise in ihrer zweiten
der großen humanitären flucht und
migrations krise in ihrer dritten
amtszeit und schließlich der korona
krise jahre in denen sie unserem land
achtung respekt so der zuneigung
erworben haben in europa und der welt
vor allem aber haben sie das vertrauen
der bürgerinnen und bürger unseres
landes geworden das ist keine leichte
aufgabe in einem land
das erst wieder lernen musste sich
selbst zutrauen
ihre entscheidungen haben sicherheit
vermittelt und verbindlichkeit
mitunter auch überrascht
es waren ihr mut in der zeit als
kriegsflüchtlinge aus syrien dorn schutz
suchten
verantwortung zu tragen nicht nur für
das eigene land
sondern für europa und es war ihre
fähigkeit das eigene selbstvertrauen in
zutrauen zu verwandeln
das überzeugt hat fähigkeiten die sie
auszeichnen und die schätzen lernte wer
den von ihnen geführten kabinetten
angehörten
für diese zeit vertrauensvoller
zusammenarbeit in unterschiedlichen
positionen will ich ihnen das sei mir
erlaubt auch persönlich langsam
wer ihnen diese großen verdienste um
unser land danken will sollte diese
sollte ihre perspektive auf die lage und
die aufgabe deutschlands in der welt
nicht aus dem blick verlieren die rolle
der mittleren in der mitte europas und
ich bin sicher dass diese rolle diese
stimme die sie haben auch in zukunft
wichtig bleiben wird für europa danke
ihnen frau bundeskanzlerin und ihnen
meine damen und herren ministerinnen und
minister für die verantwortungsvolle
regierungsarbeit der vergangenen jahre
ganz unabhängig davon wo sie ihre
politische zukunft in den kommenden
jahren sehen welche möglichkeiten sich
für sie ergeben ich will ihnen meinen
besonderen respekt
für ihre arbeit ausdrücken für ihren
dienst an der demokratie
dass unsere demokratie immer auch von
wechsel der generationen lebt
wissen wir aber es zu wissen bedeutet
nicht dass das abschied nehmen deshalb
schon leicht fällt natürlich nicht aber
die meisten von ihnen blicken auf eine
lange politische biographie zurück
und in dieser haben sie in ganz
unterschiedlichen aufgaben funktionen
und ämtern verantwortung getragen zu
unterschiedlichen zeiten
in unterschiedlichen konstellationen mal
in partnerschaft mal in gegners oft mal
mit mehr öffentlicher zustimmung
mal mit weniger
aber ich weiß weil ich viele von ihnen
lange kenne immer im dienste unseres
landes im namen unseres volkes danke ich
ihnen deshalb und wünsche ihnen für die
zukunft alles erdenklich gute
meine damen und herren
bereits heute früh habe ich sie frau
bundeskanzlerin gemäß artikel 69 absatz
3 des grundgesetzes ersucht die
geschäfte bis zur ernennung einer neuen
bundesregierung
weiter zu führen
und hierfür wünsche ich ihnen allen
weiterhin eine glückliche hand vielen
dank
frau bundeskanzlerin ich darf sie nun
mehr nach vorne bitten
[Musik]
ich verlasse die urkunde im namen der
bundesrepublik deutschland
das amtsverhältnis der bundeskanzlerin
dr angela merkel
hat mit zusammentritt des 20 deutschen
bundestages am 26 oktober 2021
seine beendigung gefunden für die dem
deutschen volke geleisteten treuen
dienste spreche ich hier dank und
anerkennung aus berlin den 26 oktober
der bundespräsident
dann gehen sie
ich glaube sie müssen augenblick noch
für die kameras
danke
der jeweils einzeln nach vorne zu treten
herr olaf scholz bundesminister der
finanzen
nimmst du dir die frohe kunde danke dir
danke
herr horst seehofer bundesminister des
innern für bau und heimat
wichtig bitten gehende gericht die
urkunde zu nehmen
dankeschön
herr heiko maas bundesminister des
auswärtigen
nimmst du dir
herr peter altmaier bundesminister für
wirtschaft und energie
frau christine lambrecht
bundesministerin der justiz und für
verbraucherschutz sowie bundesministerin
für familie senioren frauen und jugend
herr hubertus heil bundesminister für
arbeit und soziales
bitteschön
danke
frau annegret kramp karrenbauer
bundesministerium der verteidigung
bitte
danke
frau julia klöckner bundesministerin für
ernährung und landwirtschaft
danke
herr jens spahn bundesminister für
gesundheit
danke
herr andreas scheuer bundesminister für
verkehr und digitale infrastruktur
danke
frau svenja schulze bundesministerin für
umwelt naturschutz und nukleare
sicherheit
der professor jetzt schauen wir nach der
ansprache von frank walter steinmeier
die feierliche überreichung der urkunden
vorgelesen hat der bundespräsident aber
ja nur die urkunde von angela merkel
wahrscheinlich steht überall das gleiche
können nämlich jetzt mal an ich vermute
dass auch sie ja weil der gast ein
kleiner so ein kleiner zwischenfall dass
angela merkel die urkunde genommen hat
und dann sofort auf ihren platz zurück
und und dann hat er sie zurückgerufen
gesagt nee das ist jetzt auch für die
für die fotografen wirtschaftliches
müssen sie ein bisschen da wären wir
nach gehorcht im schnitt weil wir
konnten ist auch nicht so genau hören
was sie gesagt hat angela merkel nämlich
sie sagte dann okay mit jedem jahr
bundeskanzler muss man länger stehen
bleiben also
hat sie wahrscheinlich kürzere steht
seiten bei den vorherigen verabschieden
denn das ist für 69 ist also sie hat das
ja schon nach jedem kabinett eben genau
so erlebt und das ist im grunde nur eine
formalie wir haben gerade schon darüber
geredet aber sie wollten auch was
ergänzen ja genau und die müssen jetzt
auch also die dort sitzen als
geschäftsführende regierung so in dieser
zusammensetzung bis zum ende der
geschäftsführenden amtszeit zusammen
hören ist kann ein ersatzkandidat oder
keine ersatzkandidatin mehr gefunden
werden wenn denn eine ministerin aus
irgendwelchen gründen oder ein minister
ausscheidet dann muss ein anderer das
amt mit übernehmen
gut also dass heißt dass das wirklich
ganz festgelegt die bleiben beieinander
es gibt jetzt auch ein abschiedsfoto ein
gruppenfoto von den
es wird nicht wieder einen neuen festakt
gibt es gibt keine neue formalie wenn
die neue regierung ins amt gewählt wird
dann gibt es dieses kabinett in der
zusammensetzung gar nicht mehr geht auch
nicht mehr zum bundespräsidenten tritt
gar nicht mehr in erscheinung verlangt
er das ist jetzt dass die absolute
behindert hatte nach der wahl von olaf
scholz fan ist wenn sie denn zustande
kommt dann wird eben auch die neue
bundesregierung vereidigt in ähnlicher
form wie wir es heute gesehen haben dann
eben nur als vereidigung und dann
bekommen sie ihren neuen urkunden
überreicht die dann zu künftigen
minister
frank walter steinmeier hat ja relativ
ausführlich angela merkel gewürdigt
sogar mit einem rückblick auf die zeit
bevor bevor sie bundeskanzlerin wurde
das war schon sehr persönlich reden ja
gut die beiden kennen sich ja auch aus
gemeinsamer regierungszeit frank walter
steinmeier war außenminister im ersten
kabinett merkel und von daher verbindet
sie auch einige gemeinsame zeit und in
der tat kann man ja sagen jetzt geht
eine ära zu ende so langsam aber sicher
denn frau merkel hat ja durchaus die
letzten jahrzehnte kann man sagen
bundesdeutscher politik die letzten 20
jahre 25 jahre geprägt mit hat ja diese
kleine referenz an das kate gemacht dass
ich das nicht vorstellen kann dass
jemand anderes einen einwand zum
beispiel bundeskanzler werden kann oder
bundeskanzlerin werden kann frank walter
steinmeier steht hier im zentrum bei
diesem gruppenfoto es ist ja auch die
zeremonie die er diese aktien er leitet
aber lass uns noch mal zurück gehen vier
jahre vorher hat er ja ganz entscheidend
dafür gesorgt dass dieses kabinett
merkel eine große koalition also cdu csu
und die spd überhaupt wieder zustande
kam denn ohne ihn wäre es nicht passiert
in der tat kann man sagen er ist einer
der wesentlichen väter dieser koalition
zusammen mit christian lindner der die
jamaika-koalition zum damaligen
zeitpunkt abgelehnt hat und dann hat
eben frank walter steinmeier seine
eigenen ehemaligen parteifreunde
er ist ja als bundespräsident nicht
mitglied mehr muss es ja ruhen lassen
aber seine ehemaligen parteifreunde von
der spd überredet und überzeugt dass es
am ende doch gut ist für die spd in
diese große koalition einzusteigen und
man kann sagen es hat sich ja
tatsächlich rentiert hatte sich rentiert
der das hier ist eine ganze zeit lang
hat die spd sagt okay wir haben uns
viele sachen vielleicht durchbekommen
politische projekte haben durch wir
bekommen aber ende august war es ja
immer spitz auf knopf in der tat aber
ich war nie ein großer freund der
überzeugung dass man nur aus der
opposition heraus wahlen gewinnen kann
und sich neu aufstellen kann und man
kann ja sagen wer scholz nicht
vizekanzler gewesen und hätte er nicht
die fußstapfen angela merkels auch im
wahlkampf wesentlich für sich reklamiert
dann hätte die spd die wahl nicht so
gewonnen also am ende hat steinmeier den
richtigen rat gegeben
obwohl ist auch eine eine zähe
veranstaltung war der inneren und
software fehler das war ja fast so eins
im gebet so fasst
gespräche die er da geführt hatte er
dann tatsächlich alle eigentlich war für
die cdu csu was dann im grunde genommen
ein schlechter rat oder ist es einzig
und allein an ihrer
analyse der ursache geschuldet bisher
geschuldet dass angela merkel gesagt hat
nein ich trete nicht mehr an bei der
union kann man sagen das ist nicht gut
gelaufen und in der tat war ist sieht
auch daran gescheitert dass der übergang
nicht funktioniert hat ist der cdu csu
nicht gelungen nach angela merkel einen
kandidaten eine kandidatin zu
präsentieren die die wähler überzeugt
und von daher hat die cdu/csu sich das
wirklich auch selbst zuzuschreiben dass
sie am ende die bundestagswahlen nicht
mit erfolg bestreiten konnte und
vermutlich sehr wahrscheinlich jetzt in
die opposition muss
große würdigung von angela merkel von
ihrer regierungsarbeit heute durch den
bundespräsidenten die aufarbeitung
innerhalb der eigenen partei wird nur
folgen denn an der seite heute mit roten
rosen an zufall eine wettkampf
karrenbauer mal als nachfolgerin erkoren
offensichtlich von der cdu parteichef
aber dann auch nicht vehement genug
unterstützt worden wie würden sie sagen
ja man kann sagen genau man hat versucht
damit kramp karrenbauer von seiten der
früheren parteivorsitzenden merkel eine
nachfolgerin möglicherweise ins gespräch
zu bringen und dann auch zu ins amt zu
bringen aber schon bei den ersten zwei
kleineren krisen hat man am ende
entschieden dass frau kramp karrenbauer
dann doch nicht geeignet ist dann doch
nicht dem amt so gewachsen ist wie man
sich das vorstellt und von daher trägt
frau merkel auch einen anteil daran dass
die cdu jetzt bei der bundestagswahl so
schlecht abgeschnitten es ist auch
schwierig wette übergangs so richtig hat
das in der deutschen geschichte noch
nicht funktioniert dass er einen erne an
den stab weiter gegeben in der tat kann
man sagen 198 auch schon bei helmut kohl
hat es nicht geklappt wo wolfgang
schäuble als kronprinz da war diesmal
gab es keinen so richtigen kronprinzen
oder eine kronprinzessin aber man hätte
versuchen können das aufzubauen um
diesen bonus dann entsprechend im
wahlkampf für sich zu nutzen
reden wir später noch mal darüber
professoren lassen wir uns heute noch
mal wieder zurückgehen an den ort wo
heute morgen alles begann das ist ein
ort der mit superlativen verknüpft ist
aber hey mann